so I worked out for a good hour I don't
have and when I came off after I was
done I sat down and of course I still
heard the ball bouncing I look down like
this guy still working out I truly love
what I do and that's where the passion
comes from that's where the will to get
better comes from just kidding you never
take a night off even if it wasn't
calling well it was always gonna be
trying to slay the dragon
what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see exploded
onto the world now I started the mentum
E series to try to hang around people
who've done a lot more than us and
hopefully by spending a little more time
with them some of their beliefs their
mindset their work ethic sinks into us
to help us become the best version of
ourselves so today we're going to learn
from one of the best Kobe Bryant and how
to develop an insane work ethic mentor
me Kobe
[Music]
okay let's kick things off with rule
number one be driven my journey began in
Philadelphia Pennsylvania the age of
three years old my father playing
basketball my hands and me taking action
their basketball was in Kobe's blood his
dad is Joe jellybean Brian he played
eight years in the NBA before uprooting
his family to take his career overseas
as a grow older we moved to Italy while
Joe was getting used to playing in
Europe his son was also making an
adjustment in Italy
not many kids were perfecting a jump
shot but Kobe Bryant was soccer was a
big sport so he had goalposts underneath
the baskets on concrete courts which is
used to play soccer all day and I would
be one of them
and then after soccer I'd stay there for
another three four or five hours his
playing basketball it was a different
country with a different language even
though he had his family he was
essentially alone
so Kobe looked inland and developed the
relentless drive to work on his game
[Applause]
when his family moved back to
Philadelphia that time spent alone on
the court paid off as Kobe announced his
arrival to the basketball world he was
the top high school player in the
country
breaking Wilt Chamberlain scoring
records becoming a celebrity at 16
Kobe's next step may have seen damn
Bish's but with his basketball pedigree
and work ethic it was an easy decision
[Music]
yeah rule number two is work helps you
grow featuring Jay Williams you look I
always try to outwork people right
that's just how I made my mark so the
game was at 7:00 it's like you know what
I'm gonna come to the Staples Center
because we're playing this when the
Lakers had Kobe and Shaq okay this is
this is like the championship Lakers so
you know I'm gonna get there at 3
o'clock I want to make sure I make 400
made shots before I go back into the
room and then I sit in a sauna I get
ready for the game who do I see I see
Kobe Bryant already work now so once I
set my foot across that line I started
working out and so I worked out for a
good hour hour and a half and when I
came off after I was done I sat down and
of course I still heard the ball
bouncing I looked down like this guy's
total working out he was working out
like it looks like he wasn't it did
sweat when I got hurt and he's still
going and it's not like his moves are
not a lot lazy if he's doing like game
moves you know that's it they're not
unlace my shoes I'm like wanna see how
long this goes I still out there watch
another 25 minutes and they got doing it
okay looking up see didn't know go play
you know come back get in the sauna get
ready for the game that game he drops 40
ohms okay and after the game is over I'm
like Isis Chi Chi I have to understand
like why why he works like that right so
after games I'm like hey Kove like why
were you in the gym for so long is that
cuz I saw you come in
and I don't want you to know that it
doesn't matter how hard you work that
I'm willing to work harder than you wow
you just you inspire me to be better and
it was the first time I started to see
this level of competitiveness less it I
need to start doing more Wow
but you never get better if you're not
willing to put in the time and
basketball is very similar to the game
of life there's gonna be ups and downs
it's not always going to be easy they're
going to be challenges they're still
going to be curveballs thrown at me but
if you put into work and you constantly
put into work that's the only way you're
going to grow rule number three outwork
everyone all season I was just waiting
and waiting for my opportunity to come I
wanted to prove that I was better than
they thought I was you know I want to
prove to myself that I'm better than
they think I was and I was mentally
preparing myself and visualizing the
moment that would come with feel
I lead to Los Angeles Lakers to a
victory
I've been with you for a long way I the
one moment that stands out out of we've
done I don't know how many don't we've
done no play eight hundred events the
one time was 4 a.m. we went up to
practice at 4 a.m. and that was your
idea to do it well then you know all
these Nike people are like no no no no
no let's not let's not do that and then
you're like let's do it at 4 a.m. so you
got security
you got brand marketing sports marketing
going no no no no no no that's not good
you're like let's do it because that's
your sustenance I mean to me it just
makes complete sense not to us see we
all right what you usually I'm sleeping
at 4 a.m. you're here working out well I
lied about that ok so if if your job is
to try to be the best basketball player
you can be alright to do that you have
to practice you have to train right
you want to train as much as you can as
often as you can
so if you get up at 10:00 in the morning
train at 11/9/12 say 12:00 train at
12:00 train for two hours 12:00 to 2:00
you have to let your body recover so you
eat recovered whatever you get back out
you train start training it at 6:00
train from 6 to 8 all right and now you
go home and shall we eat dinner you go
to bed you wake up do it again right
those are two sessions all right now
imagine you wake up at 3:00 you train at
4:00 you go 4 to 6 come home
breakfast relax so so now you're back at
it again 9 to 11 right relax and now
it's on your back at it again to the 4
and have you're back at it again you
know 7 to 9
look how much more training I have done
by simply starting at 4 all right and so
now you do that and as the years go on
the separation that you have with
through competitors and your peers just
grows larger and larger and larger and
larger and larger and by year five or
six doesn't matter what kind of work
they're doing a summer they're never
going to catch up because they're five
years behind so it makes sense to get up
and start your day early because you can
get more working is that genetic or is
that something you you engrained and
trained yourself no it was just you that
for me it was it was just common sense
like I can okay if I start earlier
can train more hours and I know the
other guys aren't doing it because I
know what their training schedule is so
I know if I do this consistently over
time
it's the gaps just gonna widen and why
no why no why no why and they won't be
able to get that back mm-hmm
so it's me it was just common sense I'm
like thinking how can I get an advantage
Oh start earlier yeah let's do that when
did you start doing that and in high
school high school we start my first
class on high school was seven at 7:45 I
used to get to the gym around 5:00 a.m.
and I'd play before school mmm and then
school with stars playing with you at
5:00 a.m. my coach my coach would show
up and we do all these basketball drills
mm-hmm so just you and your coach just
me and my coach and sometimes it would
just be me and a janitor who's still
there today
and and then I play at lunch I can't you
get a medal
III I hooked him up with a few things
but I played no lunch and then practice
after and then go home to my schoolwork
and then watch a bunch of game film and
games on TV and study study film how do
you develop that or where do you what do
you learn that from well I I think it's
just no it's just a matter of what's
important to you mm-hmm
what's important to you for whatever
reason you know I felt like I didn't
feel good about myself if I wasn't doing
everything I could to be the best
version of myself if I felt like I left
anything on the table it would eat away
at me I wouldn't be able to look myself
in the mirror right so the reason why I
can retire it now and be completely
comfortable about it because I know that
I've done everything I could to be the
best basketball player I could be and so
that's where it comes from for me you
can't leave any stone unturned
rule number four love what you do don't
you explain that mindset of just trying
to continuously improve I enjoy what I
do you know this is fun for me
you know III truly love what I do and
that's where the passion comes from
that's where the will to get better
comes from is just because I truly enjoy
I enjoy the preparation the high school
coach Greg Donner it says that you might
actually be a little in
barish by how much you love basketball
yeah is that true probably yeah I mean
well it's like well I mean it's like
anything you know I I just so happened
to be playing basketball like if I was a
computer kid you know in high school
people would have probably been in front
of me you know what I mean it just so
happened to be basketball what I'm
passionate about my passion knows no
bounds but it embarrasses you well I
mean just a little little weird a little
strange I mean when you're around like
in the Olympics I'm around all the
athletes who kind of share that same
then I say my same mind said it's it's
fun to be around though because you can
have conversations about those things
rule number five make one move at a time
I wish you have the passionate thing
that you're passionate about now you can
look at other people or other entities
or other things or works of art and you
can draw things from that to help you be
better at what you do
by looking for those common denominators
I don't even know how do I prepare ever
how do I prepare how do I study how do I
view the game how do you build your game
and my response is much like the way he
builds products and you think
sequentially oh yeah you look at this
the end result of what you want to
create but in order to create that
there's so many other little things that
go into this massive entity that or
device it's no different than building
my basketball game you start with what
do you want your game to be will we make
your game most unstoppable or hard to
deal with and now you work backwards
from there
and you start building in one piece at a
time one move at a time one counter
there's a lot of similarities there and
rule number six the last one before the
special bonus clip is achieve greatness
[Music]
Kobe Bryant now he gets gonna be
retiring yeah I've never season one you
said what is this candy his 20th season
all have known the greatest careers in
basketball Austria will not allow them
to be what you want was any longer no
one understand what it takes to be great
the force that drives you to do what
others don't
the sacrifice is made I would one
purpose in mind
push yourself and become better the
extra seconds minutes hours of work put
into perfecting one's game lifting
yourself above the rest to make sure
your name will forever be synonymous
with one word greatness what does it
take to be great work at the
determination drive takes ability it
takes the desire moves on muscle again
turns it I think it takes years of
players relying on you to take the big
shot make the great play you'll do the
things that bring success to the team
that's that's what it's all about is
getting out and measuring yourself
against others and I think that when you
have an attitude like that that's what I
think that's part of greatness the first
time met Kobe Kobe was missing out of
high school he's out here before work up
and I've never seen anyone work out as
hard
this is coated I've never seen anybody
that prepared he was 17 years old and
was ready to play NBA basketball that's
that's pretty amazing and I think Jerry
West was the one who said this he said I
want this kid because this kid had more
talent than anybody I have a plan for me
right now and he had a great team
just kidding would never take a night
off even if it wasn't calling well it
was always gonna be trying to slay the
dragon if you don't have that type of
work ethic you don't get to enjoy the
benefits
[Applause]
[Music]
now I've got a very special bonus clip
on how to have a schedule like Kobe
Bryant that I think you're gonna enjoy
but first my question the day what was
the single greatest Lakers Kobe Bryant
team
what year leave it down the comments
below I'm really curious to find out
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope we continue to
believe in yourself and whatever you're
one where it is
much love I'll see you soon and enjoy
the bonus
can you walk us through like in a 24
hour stretch the regime you put your
body through i mean it's intense yeah
well since uh you know since I started
kind of picking up the training to go
through a schedule my day I get up at
6:00 in the morning I started doing
training but for about an hour or so
from 6 to about 7 7 15 take my kids to
school and then go straight to the
practice silly and lift weights for
about an hour and then go out on the
court do a little extra shooting for an
hour and then practice starts and then
after practice do some more shooting and
go back home and when this particular
day I'd run the track and then come back
home and do another recovery therapy
session and the day with a nice bath so
it's a full day not much sleep now I'm
going to sleep but then you gotta you
know you also got to mix in there you
know club soccer and stuff like that
right you know so to pull there the most
important work ever if you had to think
of one word that's most important to you
or that sums you Apple that would be
like a little beacon pay believe nation
if you want to know what the most
important one word is for Tony Robbins
Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey will.i.am
and Howard Schultz I have a very special
secret video for you check the
description for details
[Music]